devant l'envolée des nouveaux cas de
kovy 19 boris johnson resserre la vis si
depuis jeudi dernier
80% de la population sont de nouveau
soumis à un confinement strict le
premier ministre a décidé ce lundi soir
de réinstaurer un confinement pour toute
l'angleterre avec la majorité du pays
déjà soumise à des mesures extrêmes
il est clair que nous devons faire plus
ensemble pour maîtriser ce nouveau
variant pendant le déploiement de nos
vaccins
wahou maxime godart cela signifie que le
gouvernement vous demande à nouveau de
rester chez vous
conséquence de ces nouvelles
restrictions les écoles resteront
fermées sur l'ensemble du territoire
il sera interdit de sortir sauf pour
aller faire ses courses
faire du sport ou si le travail en
présentiel et nécessaire nous devons
maintenant faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour arrêter la propagation de
la maladie des écoles primaires les
écoles secondaires et les universités à
travers l'angleterre doivent passer à
des services à distance à partir de
demain sauf pour les enfants vulnérables
et les enfants des travailleurs des
secteurs clés tout le monde sera
toujours en mesure d'accéder aux
structures dédiées à la petite enfance
telles que les crises sanchez nasri à
l'instar de l'angleterre le pays de
galles et l'irlande du nord ce sont des
jarres confiné respectivement depuis les
20 et 26 décembre dernier en écosse
la première ministre nicolas store
jeunes a également choisi de durcir les
dispositions en vigueur et a opté ce
lundi pour un nouveau confinement
nationale pendant l'intégralité du mois
de janvier pour que le vaccin gagne
cette course il est essentiel
d'accélérer la vaccination autant que
possible mais pour lui donner le temps
nécessaire pour prendre le dessus
nous devons également ralentir le virus
et comme il se propage plus rapidement
maintenant cela signifie que des
restrictions encore plus sévères sont
nécessaires nous constatons actuellement
une forte tendance à la hausse des
infections
en effet il n'est pas exagéré de dire
que je suis plus préoccupé par la
situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui que je ne l'étais
à n'importe quel autre moment depuis
mars dernier la découverte du nouveau
variant du coc vite 19 il y a quelques
semaines a rendu la propagation du bien
incontrôlable dans l'ensemble du royaume
depuis sept jours le nombre de cas
recensés quotidiennement dépasse
systématiquement les 50000 personnes